&gt;&gt; Early on, we saw that if we have a compound inequality that's written in a
chained form like this, it's really the same as having two inequalities joined
together with an and. We know that with this inequality, x needs to lie between
negative 2 and 6, where 2 is included in the interval. So it's true that both x
is greater than or equal to negative 2, then we have x is less than 6. Let's
graph each of these individually on a number line, and then, the compound
inequality on a third one. First we have that x is greater than or equal to
negative 2, or in other words, that negative 2 is less than or equal to x. Then
we have, x is less than 6. And then if we graph these two together, what we're
really doing is finding the shaded part of the number line between the two that
overlaps. So, if for example, I lay this number line on top of this number line,
and I then shade in the part that's overlapping, I get exactly what we have in
the compound inequality down here, because of the and. We have a double
restriction happening, and that further reins in the values that x can equal to
this smaller range than we would have if we had either one of these true on its
own.